[Musik]
ein gegner ist zum nahm das spiel zu
verlassen
[Musik]
da müsste man es hier
da kommen hätte da kommen welche luca da
kommen sie da kommt sagt okay ich bin
hinter uns alter ich franz max wir
kommen nicht wieder
ich habe hast du hast mich stein nicht
gegeben luca die treppe hochlaufen junge
sg lauf noch glaubhafter flaf narro mein
gott nicht ins fliegen doch gar keinen
fall ins mieten die konnten sie kommen
sie kommen jetzt entspannt jetzt jetzt
jetzt jammern
okay wir es geschafft
[Musik]
schon wieder ich ja gewonnen
du musst ja gerade welche glauben ich
denke das kann ich versprechen halten
werk von mir oder hast du das gedrehte
es ist einfach so hin hat was wir machen
mein name ist khan herzlich willkommen
wir heute seine neuen folge war wird
schauen jetzt auf den server wir haben
es tatsächlich geschafft sind mist amor
game entkommen und wir haben heute
wieder einen change für euch am start
ich würde sagen drei zwei eins und los
auf dem server
ich bin schon drauf drei sekunden
angesagt war aber ich denke uns wird
keiner nach tollen und vor allem das
ding ist auch also muri und seine
freundin sind einfach direkt neben uns
gewesen allerdings haben sie uns nicht
gesehen falls ihr wissen wollt ihr das
ganze passiert ist altrandsberg wir
kommen hier nicht hoch wie gesagt ich
hab's du hast mich schlau nicht gegeben
luca ich finde sie geht die treppe hoch
schaut euch einmal die letzte folge an
und mein gott es ins paradies
ja man ok apropos es ins paradies das
ist jetzt unsere oberste priorität
wir bauen erst mal einen ofen max die
oberste priorität ist die heutige
challenge das stimmt natürlich wir haben
es nämlich an war wohl so gemacht die
erste folge weiter wenn ich du wäre
folge wo wir unsere koordinaten
offenbart haben wo bist du
ich bin hier vorne weil hier noch ein
hühnchen ist drei hühnchen
die erste folge war eine wenig tue ihre
folge wo wir unsere koordinaten unter
anderem offenbart haben wenn ich du wäre
würde ich einfach mal unsere koordinaten
in den chats schreiben in der zweiten
folge habe die ganze zeit gepflegt und
uns gegenseitig backpfeifen gegeben mehr
oder weniger weil wir immer
unterschiedliche wörter gesagt haben wo
wir vorher gesagt haben dass sie nicht
sagen dürfen auch gott
[Musik]
und jetzt in der dritten folge haben wir
uns gedacht wir haben hier so ein paar
wäscheklammern die spielen einfach mal
ab und zu schere stein papier und damit
ihr versteht das geht wirklich sagen
machen wie es direkt mal und zwar
schreibt eine wahl in den chat rund 321
mussolini wäscheklammer jetzt muss ich
mir eine wäscheklammer irgendwo ins
gesicht knipsen und die für den rest der
aufnahme am körper ich habe jetzt mein
rechtes ohr gewählt ok dahinter und
hühnchen mit dem müssen wir mal ein
hühnchen rupfen
ich blende euch jetzt mal ein nähe ich
bin euch eins sagen ich dafür gar nicht
nebenbei einblenden ich bin keine ahnung
hier sind schaut euch einfach max folge
an
denn ihr das sehen wollt heißt luca der
typ aus dem video da ich werde euch
einfach mal ab jetzt die face kämpfern
max oben rechts in der ecke ein in
addition zu meiner face camp oben links
einfach so jetzt mal ab jetzt in den
weiteren verlauf des videos damit ihr
einfach sieht wenn man sich
beispielsweise klammer die fresse haut
wie das dann quasi direkt bei ihnen
aussieht wäre das vielleicht interessant
für die weiteren folgen rauch also
machst du nicht machen hier als auch
öfters challenge ist dann eigentlich in
jeder folge war eine challenge also wenn
ihr wollt dass ich hab jetzt in jeder
folge ein doppelfenster mache also max
und ich in den beiden ecken damit ihr
direkt beides seht dann lasst man fällt
leichter und schreib mal face kam in die
kommentare
jetzt geht es weiter mit warum
ja genau
macht es einfach ich hole noch ein
bisschen holz und sonne ja ok aber merkt
ihr mal dass du immer hierher zurück
kommst so müssen jetzt auch noch was
machen aus dem übrig gebliebenen
rohstoffen ich bin so happy dass wir
tatsächlich entkommen sind erst mal
spielen wir auch mal schwere stein
papier würde ich sagen ich will jetzt
nur 321 schon wieder ich habe gewonnen
hatte wäscheklammern ich habe extra zehn
stück hier aus diesem anlass ich
vertraue dadurch noch mal ändern weil
ich habe jetzt schon die nase genommen
du hast nichts mehr ändern aber man hört
es nicht so krass okay das ist schon mal
gut
luca es gibt hier gebracht und schicken
du brauchst auch noch was zu essen hier
ich habe ein halbes jahrhundert heute
kannst mir hinzuschmeißen
ich habe hier schon drei stücken
geworfen ok danke ich mir sofort
geworfen so luca jetzt bist du aber man
soll ich fordere dich noch mal heraus zu
schere stein papier und schere stein
papier gut ich nehme ich nehme aber die
nase kommen wenn du schon leider seit
ich mein gott sind die engen dass das
das geht nicht das passt nicht meine
nase
ich habe mir da nicht bei mir doch auch
nicht so hey lass mich los
das kann nicht wahr sein als er ihnen
bestimmt von den ersten videos ich kann
ich mal wie die schlucken ist so wie ich
leide gerade noch aber leute lukas kling
original wie seinem ersten video ist nur
wie max
komm lass mal ein bisschen umziehen ich
meine wir sind jetzt da wo die partielle
stein papier scheiße leiter wolf wir
müssen die wegschieben von der nase weg
ja weil wir auch lasst uns sagen dass
wir gleich wo bist du über dir läuft nun
mal vor gericht
wir brauchen eine höhle wir müssen jetzt
wirklich mal schaffen diese folge von ai
und zu bekommen die andere haben
wahrscheinlich schon all dies ist jetzt
ja da hinten ist ein sehr gut
ok also bist du hinter mir ich bin beim
schwein aber wir müssen wir dürfen uns
nicht verlieren erfolgt wie folgt ich
bin hinter dir und herlaufen
[Musik]
wir suchen jetzt erstmal so rede ich
halt wirklich normal wenn ich mich jetzt
nicht irgendwie anstrengend nicht durch
die nase zu atmen kann reden noch nicht
schränkt mich überhaupt nicht an
so werde ich auch noch mal aber meine
damen sind einfach voll zugehalten und
würde eine höhle einfach ja also wir
brauchen wir brauchen vor allen dingen
wirklich eine natürliche würde
weil sonst haben wir dieses problem
glaube ich und es wird auch gerade
nachts luca wo bist du denn da hier
rechts hinter der hinter dir sagen der
erste essen mitnehmen essen mitnehmen
muss und dass es richtig ist es eine
höhle
das ist alles keine höhe sind nur
wasserlöcher alter samt 14-jähriger
papierkorb ok schere stein papier nur 30
sekunden vor anderes ohr
ich glaube da vorne vor den zombies
gesichtern legen wir mal ich hab halt
immer noch kein bisschen löst luca ist
so peinlich eigentlich zum krieg
bestimmt ordentlich levitch
ja das schöne dinge von mir das problem
ok konnten folgt mir mal bitte ich
glaube da vorne waren heute okay es sind
viel zu viele monster hier dargestellt
habe mir ja auch überall springen
sprinten
als sie weg von mir oder hast du das
geräte es ja doch etwas bitte und
schnitt bei der dekra ok und hat sich
noch weg von marx kopf kopf ich kann ja
nicht sprinten gerade okay jetzt kann
ich wieder springen ist dass vorsicht
vorsicht
sie können uns runterschubsen die
viecher okay wäre noch eine spinne tanz
ich habe alles gut der ist klar der fall
italien wo lage bei anlagen können
jemand rief abbas auf dich ich brauche
dringend rüstung
hier sind wir nicht mehr mitregieren da
vorne ist eine
zunächst luca ich das alles decker also
erstmal wir brauchen unbedingt diese
folge wohl ein wir haben noch acht
minuten
das können wir ja ich hab schon ab
nikolov vom aufbau her ich habe hier
immer aufgebaut gerade hier und steht
eine okay hier ist noch mehr eis asse
schon drei klappern in der fresse ja ich
habe drei okay aber 4 3 3 3 1 1 1
die macht über mich gleich alter aber
meine ohren fallen langsam ab alter bist
du richtig weh aber ich mag er ist das
einzige rein 28 alter table
und das so muss das war hier geht noch
was geworden entdecken junge wie mache
ich die behindert war videos jorin es
ist nicht mehr normal gerade bei uns
[Musik]
fast schon rollt taylor kann ich mir
schon mal wie ich packe selbst nicht
klar war noch dran
ja ich habe kräftig sable hier ans ohr
erst angepackt
ich habe das einzige eingepackt ich
musste steve denkt also ich mache den
haaren stand ja bitte hier wachsen
wir sind ziemlich viele mops okay war
ich ziemlich kurz zurück doch für dich
ja ich komme ja ich komme zurück hast du
noch einen spinnen spinnen farben 2
gibt's du mir mal habe ich dir geben
alter ist kurzfristig will darauf
erstmal schere stein papier wäre zwar
ein tor vorbei ja auf mich bei der
geburt die mindestgebote ok chef irvin
stahl papier
okay dass ich habe schiris nicht ist
nicht auch wenn ich danach erst getippt
habe kein stress alter eine nase tut so
weh hier nehme einen bogen noch meine
nase tut so weh ich habe den bogen
ergeben ja
das tut auch sowie noch mit knapp 26
ticks
wie ging nochmal auf die schule
ok ich hab' das falsche ja ich glaube
die haben wir erstmal alles leer gemacht
wie bisschen tiefer würde ich sagen oder
pasta essen auch bei kohle wie viel
essen haben wir noch also wenn ich mache
hat relativ viele wer aber auch wenn
dort noch fünf minuten glaube ich also
ok also ich würde sagen wir haben
einigermaßen vernünftig aufgeholt
gerade denken dass wir scheiße macht die
ganze zeit
ich bin echt das geht klar ich hätte
gedacht wir sind schlechter darauf
erstmal schere stein papier bis 20 kw
ich muss meinen ich meine nase an leute
okay man sieht nicht so krass aber jetzt
nur noch weg taxe drauf proben aus der
tod probieren ein nasenloch aus dass
sich auch in neueste variation mein gott
okay wir müssen irgendwie tiefer rein
lasst alles abbauen oder das ist doch
alles sofort fällig bevor wir nachher
wieder kein essen habe mac auf bestimmte
war die kohle hier sowas ab doch nicht
bei ja schön um es mir keine zeit
verschwenden
erst 33 dinge müssen noch locker 3 ich
habe drei du im 2 ja es ist klar an
dieser stelle hier noch mal ganz kurz
ein kleiner einschub hier von mir ich
habe gerade gesagt eigentlich habe ich
schon dreimal verloren
google bezieht ich habe irgendwie
vergessen diese wäscheklammer darauf zu
tun als gegenleistung klatsche ich mir
jetzt eine weiter gehen jetzt tut mir
leid wir dann noch mal zwei runden
hintereinander spielen
ok ich höre da was haben wir aber okay
wollen wir ja ok
3 es war ja so spielt ja soja 3 2 1 los
scheiße und noch eine runde direkt drei
hornschuh sowie okay sagt 321 macht das
kind ich hab's kim genommen alter
schwede
guckt euch unbedingt auch lukas
perspektive an jack sparrow mainz
einfach so behindert was wir machen ob
wir wollen hier etwas mitnehmen
ja okay ich will die fällt ab ich muss
mir ich hab augenbrauen und sich nicht
mehr wie vorher
man muss nach noch wohin er irgendwo
weiter runter weiter runter kommen aber
die hier geht es runter ja ich mag es
hier ich bin ja ich bin da
du bist hier ist also sollte ich mal die
prior sein fahrrad braucht ja das wäre
krass alter wohl soviel iron mit ghana
werkzeugen auch privates gerade auf mich
oder sehr gut die anderen haben bestimmt
aber also wir hatten beide den eindruck
als wir unser material wo wir mister
moore und bruce hatten sah es aus als
hätten die von allen kassen erst einmal
runter bauen lassen und aber meinst du
er ist egal kompakt ich folge dir
wir haben noch eineinhalb minuten das
leben ist einfach krass wie wäre es mit
einer runde stehen papiere konnten
darauf dass er noch leben schere stein
papier ist alles so wie schere stein
papier muss ich konnte stein stein weiß
am schnellsten
ich mache hier hier hier hier lama weist
ein gutes zeichen
alternativ browser zu b
er sagt klar was uns zeigt
ja weil aber sind doch auch diamanten
klar ist auch auf der tod okay was
machen wir jetzt
das tut nur weh ich habe da jetzt alter
doch er ist jedoch wenig kannst dich
machen
mir tut es auch weh alter ja ich muss
abnehmen ich habe heute sehe ich gar
nicht mal richtig auf der einen seite
läuft erstmal und das denken möglich
sicher ich habe ich finde wie eine höhle
aber es tut so weh mir doch auch bei mir
doch auch leute was war just like dazu
sich rw mexikaners nicht dass du noch
wie ich muss ich muss abnehmen lassen
sagen in dem abkommen
beim ja okay du hast du verloren
ja ich habe leute ich gehe mal kurze
face cam meine ohren alter abdrücke von
den scheiß klammern hey ich habs
schneider über allem einer schloss
rechtlich zu kommen komm komm runter zu
mir du kannst hier stehe
wie stehst du jura co ja ich habe auch
keine spitzhacke wäre mir tut alles weh
weniger die schmerzhafteste waro folge
mein ort tut richtig was sowas nicht
nochmal machen nein leute wenn ihr
übrigens ideen für challenges habt könnt
ihr uns ja und in die kommentare
schreiben so was die beispielsweise
spielt man mit handschuhen oder kinder
über kreuz oder irgendwas anderes was
vielleicht nicht so weh tut mir jetzt
gerade aber dann erst mal leute wenn
euch die folge gefallen hat las man
leichter und schaut euch auf jeden fall
max folge an und dann würde ich sagen
sie wir uns in der nächsten folge wieder
yaman wir sehen uns ja ihr müsst mich
normal ertragen wie ich das im letzten
war opa hat auch schon macht hat mache
ich hier wieder so eine ent card und
zwar findet ihr hier die letzte folge
bahro eingeblendet wenn ihr euch dafür
interessiert wie das ganze hier alles
entstanden ist und hier findet ihr einen
smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
krieg könnte meinen kanal abonnieren das
ist kostenlos und sie nimmt an einem
gewinnspiel von der playstation 4 teil
also wahre folge main kanal abonnieren
super
[Musik]